en effet le thé qui boivent chaque matin
désormais ces consommateurs pourront
répondre à cette question il visite
aujourd'hui le site de production de la
société dahmane faire grâce à
l'opération découvrez ce que vous mangez
le créateur de thé donne l'occasion à
des amateurs d'entrevoir ce equis on
accueille le grand public et on leur
fait faire un parcours dans nos ateliers
de production et en finit par des
dégustations de produits pour pouvoir
leur expliquer en toute transparence ce
que nous faisons ce que nous leur
offrons en dégustation l'événement est
organisé par l'association nationale des
industries agroalimentaires
comme dammann frères près d'une centaine
d'entreprises du secteur de
l'agroalimentaire ouvrent leurs portes
au public
difficile d'imaginer l'envers du décor
d'une telle usine pour les visiteurs
découvrir cet entrepôt où sont stockés
500 tonnes de thé est non seulement une
chance mais aussi une surprise le thé
dahmane il est vraiment super bon très
réputé et j'avais envie de connaître un
petit peu les coulisses quoi tout
simplement voir un peu comment cet effet
et je suis vraiment agréablement
surprise c'est impressionnant parce que
je pensais que c'était encore plus gros
que ça et
et on voit bien que c'est une entreprise
à taille humaine après une visite des
locaux place au test de l'odorat au bout
en passant par le toucher tous les sens
sont mises à contribution pour affiner
ses connaissances en matière de thé
c'est très intéressant ça permet de
découvrir des nouveaux parfums des
nouveaux assemblages
je connais déjà l'été dahmane puisque
j'en consomme régulièrement et là ça a
permis des quotas m'a permis de
découvrir encore de nouvelles saveurs
l'initiative augmentera peut-être la
consommation de thé en france les
français en boivent en moyenne 250
grammes chaque année soit 7 fois moins
tu nous voisins